you
[Music]
thank you for coming in true Lukas
fashion we're only four minutes late so
thanks for coming this morning my name
is Lukas Joppa I'm the chief
environmental scientist for Microsoft
I'm also the chair of this session so so
you will have to put up with me for the
next bit of time here I am pretty
excited about what we have for you today
because we have three fantastic speakers
we've got milling tombe from USC
Carla Gomez from Cornell and Tanya
burger wolf from UIC all talking about
this topic AI for Earth which is really
about applying the latest advances in
artificial intelligence and academic
research to the environmental sciences
it's a topic of passion for me it's what
I've concentrated my entire career on
I've had the opportunity of working as a
researcher in MSR for the past seven
years until moving out into this new
corporate role to direct a new program
for Microsoft called AI for Earth so
this is a faculty summit session but
it's also sitting in a much broader
context which is one of the first
programs that Microsoft's rolling out
across the company dedicated to bringing
the full power of yes Rai technologies
but also the 35 years of research that
we've done in this space to areas of
significant societal impact our programs
really set up to focus on four key areas
which you can see here agriculture water
climate change in biodiversity
conservation and there's three real
pillars to the program first is simply
providing access to our technologies so
as your grants and those are available
to academics working in this space so we
are definitely looking for proposals
please visit our website if you just go
to asher for research you will see an AI
for earth call for proposals we would
love to hear the ideas that any of you
might have or any of your colleagues who
aren't fortunate enough to be here today
might have to take advantage of some of
our resources
we are also working on creating a bunch
of training programs for bringing people
on campus for multi-day in-depth
trainings around some of our
technologies I know that for in some
cases that is a problem for academics
and in some cases it's not but if people
are interested please let us know and
then there's also opportunities to work
directly with us as teams at Microsoft
whether it's Microsoft research
scientists or others across the company
on these programs so I'm not going to
say much more about that the way that
we've structured today is to have each
of our speakers come up I'm going to do
my level best I know each of them so
it's probably going to fail but I'm
going to do my best to keep them to 20
minutes each we're not going to ask
questions immediately after each speaker
because I really want to be able to
bring all three of them up here at once
and allow a broader question and answer
session for for all of this
so we'll be we'll be hearing from Carlos
Carla first then Tanya then milind in
that order so please just any questions
that you have as during or immediately
after their talks
hold for the broader Q&A session and
with that thank you very much and we'll
bring Carla hello it's great to be here
and thank Lucas for organizing this a
great session so today I'm going to give
you a bit of an overview of computation
sustainability computing for a better
world and you know I actually now when I
give my talks I really feel that this is
you know a collaborative effort so it is
important to acknowledge my
collaborators and also NSF that has
funded this research in fact you know
NSF provided us with two
expeditions in computing a word that
really allowed us to you know new create
this field and this is we have now
consciousness a large research network
involving several universities and in
fact Mullane this part of consciousness
Stephan all from Stanford and willing
from USC and bistra should be also from
Georgia Tech so this is a large research
network and I want to tell you a little
bit about that Doug Fischer is also here
from Vanderbilt and am I missing so so
again a large research effort so what is
computation sustainability basically you
know the the big picture is to harness
AI and computer science to address key
challenge concerning sustainable
development this year the notion of
sustainable results
was introduced back in 87 by the United
Nations the revelation of the
revolutionary notion at the time and
ultimately it is the goal of sustainable
development is human well-being and
therefore sustainable development
encompasses balancing environmental
economic and societal needs and you see
the 17 goals of sustainable development
there we have a variety of projects
concerning computational sustainability
I will focus on you know projects at
Cornell and this projects range from the
you know balling social economic needs
conservation and biodiversity to
accelerating discovery of new materials
for solar fuel so I hope to give you a
bit of some you know detail about these
examples no technical details so but to
give you a sense of the kinds of
research that you are
but at the same time I do want you to
take the message that you know this is a
very exciting area in terms of research
for computer science and in fact I want
to point out that we have a variety of
projects because they really you know
are important as computer science for us
to identify cross-cutting computational
themes and apply them across different
domains and you know we focus on big
data and machine learning constraints
reasoning automated reasoning
optimization and citizen science citizen
science is actually plays a key role
when it comes to these kinds of efforts
so and and again you know what you know
as a computer science this is exciting
because this really pushes the
boundaries of the state of the art and a
lot of the key questions actually
we cannot just work as we used to in a
little area now we really have to work
at the intersection for example
optimization and machine learning etc so
here I have another perspective of the
different projects actually these are
projects of direct contrast net and what
I'm trying to emphasize here is again
that a variety of projects really have
this cross-cutting computational theme
so what you see here is the line this is
a subway line and each line corresponds
to computational theme and so then we
have several projects along this line
and again I will talk a little bit about
this project during my talk and I'll
start with wildlife conservation as you
know since the Industrial Revolution we
have witnessed a dramatic reduction in
biodiversity a key cause for
biodiversity reduction is habitat loss
and fragmentation
and so you know biologists ecologists
really think that it's important to
maintain landscape connectivity too you
know linking core biological areas to
increase the allow movement between
areas and increase genetic diversity he
is actually there was a very nice piece
back in 2006 in the science section of
the New York Times talking about this
project the Yellowstone - Yukon you know
the idea is to link these two important
areas with wildlife corridor for four
different species and we actually in
collaboration with the Rocky Mountain
Research Station part of the u.s. Forest
Service worked on designing corridors
for grizzly bears and other species and
just for you to see how this is actually
a simple
I mean how it translates into a
computational question you want to
connect these three reserve
Yellowstone's almost always in Glacier
Park and you can represent you know this
the different parcels with nodes and
then in this graph you have so the nodes
correspond to parcels and there's an
edge if you a bear can go from one
parcel to the other and now you have the
reserve so your goal is to connect this
and form a corridor if you just want the
minimal cost solution this is a well
known problem in it could be the science
the Steiner tree problem and basically
in fact I'm just reminding you this is
what's exactly when you we are setting
up a connection for video conference we
are solving it you know all the
computers
behind-the-scenes a stylet e problem so
that means that you know we can actually
leverage tremendous advancements from
network design to study these problems
in particular for example for landscape
connectivity but you know what's also
interesting is that you know this
problems pose new challenge for example
we need to factor in different species
different requirements and they need to
new methodologies that we can then you
know generalize for other applications
so this two-way street is really makes
it exciting
also for computer scientists and using
you know variety of variety of
techniques we we actually could can
produce optimal or Miyata MO corridor
designs and for example we show that the
minimum cost corridor for the grizzly
bears would be around 8 million which is
less than an SF expedition so if you
have more money you can actually do
better and you know we worked on
generalizing this for other other other
species and actually we have a very
interesting collaboration with Ecuador
actually involving several researchers
and the idea is to build the social
ecological corridors for the onion bear
which is a key and umbrella species in
Ecuador and South America and by you
know designing corridors for these
species we automatically can see the
many other species this is a more
challenging problem because now you
really need to also consider you know
the the social implications and support
the local communities actually bistra is
also part of this this project I thought
I would now talk briefly another project
concerning
[Music]
evaluating the impacts of them for
proliferation in the Amazon basin this
is actually Alex factor is an ecologist
actually right here and keeps putting
together these you know amazing team of
ecologists biologists sediment
specialists hydrologist etc and so here
and just to give you an idea for the in
the next 10 or 15 years they have
planned or they have under construction
or plans for more than 500 dams in the
Amazon so that will have tremendous
implications in terms of ecosystem
services and in terms of obviously
energy but also it may affect negatively
transportation connectivity fisheries
etc so just so we are working on this
problem and you imagine you know
different configurations will have
different impact in terms of ecosystem
service and here I show how for example
in terms connectivity this one really is
worse than than this one and for example
we are looking at the trade-offs here
you see we study the trade-off in terms
of energy and connectivity for the
Western Amazon and in scenario a we
don't you get much energy so this is the
energy access and connectivity and so we
get a lot of connectivity and that's
what we see we show here now if you
increase energy now you see you remove
big chunks of the network so the
connectivity goes starts going down and
you can see now you have high levels of
energy and
the connectivity is those down
dramatically so we are working on you
know extend here we are also working on
the criticality of understanding
criticality of them for example the
solution on the left is much worse than
the one on the right because it really
you know blocked the main stands of the
rivers and the output of some of these
dams actually is not very high so we are
extending this work for you know the
Amazon and for a variety of ecosystem
service for example now we can generate
the Pareto frontier for for this that
involves about nine thousand solutions
so we are looking at these different
options so how do we you know relate our
models to data to to to the real world
we basically need NATO and we use data
from you know all kinds of sensors
remote sensing land settle the land
satellite etc and and we also use an
amazing sensor that you know the best
sensor so no no doubt this is the best
sensor for example for recognizing
species and in fact the level of
Ornithology at Cornell has this great
program
Ebert it's a citizen transfer program
that you know with over 300,000
volunteer borders that have submitted
over 300 million bird observations left
to respond to over 22 million hours of
field work three times that 2,500 years
of field work more than three times the
level that went into the building the
Empire State Building
so combining those data with
environmental data
and using computational resources such
as you know the Microsoft your we we can
you know relate the environmental
predictors to the patterns of occurrence
and absence of species using machine
learning models and that's what you see
here this is actually the output of a
machine learning model and so now we
know you know we can identify birds
migrations and and these models also
reveal the habitat preference of the
birds that's a very fine resolution
which allows us to have new novel models
for conservation and a great example is
this the Nature Conservancy has this
program called bird returns to protect
migratory migratory waterbirds
in the California against the drought
and basically this is a communitarian
reverse option where you know farmers
submit bids to keep water in the in the
rice fields who in siding with the bird
migration so that is only possible
because of this very fine resolution
Ebert models using this program they
have created substantial additional
habitat for the water birds and this is
really only possible because of you know
this now very powerful computational
models with a very fine resolution in
terms of habitat preference etc just let
me mention that we have a similar
citizen science program in in Africa to
get you know beetle Farge maps for
Africa contrarily to the u.s. Africa
very poorly sensed and I also wanted to
mention a project step
no Armand is leading this project on
using satellite imagery and machine
learning to predict poverty there are
some issues then you know one of them is
you know citizen science is great but
you know there are limitations for
example because if they are volunteers
we can't really tell them go here or
there so bias you know in data bias is a
real problem so we are developing games
to really based on this principle agent
model to really incentivize birds us to
go to the places where we need data and
this again from a commutation point of
view this is a very interesting problem
and basically you know this is you may
have heard a Pokemon go well this is the
real version of Pokemon though where we
did with points to to boil the soup they
collect and at the end of the season
they're the lottery where they gain
Bernard was proportional to the number
of so the chance of getting the vinegar
is proportional to the point they
collect and you know we were amazed to
see emerges our ideal or borders are
really the best citizen science you can
think of because they actually are so
fanatic and dedicated and we saw that
with this application game we could
really move them to understand both
areas I have just I'm trying to really
say I have five minutes I thought I
would now mention a very different area
that we are also very excited about and
that concerns using you know AI and
computational techniques to accelerate
material discovery for
solar fuels you know the Obama in 2010
created the materials genome initiative
to accelerate and incentivize the pace
of discovery we are working with the
Joint Center for artificial fantasy this
is on so love yourself the the cool part
about solar fuels is that they can be
stored and used later as opposed to just
you know solar and panels so this is a
very exciting area for computer science
and basically just to give you an idea
how this works you know they have this
high school put experiments where they
they have like an apparatus like
freegans where they they they read like
say three massive like atomic spray
painting they mix up material so they
can rapidly synthesize thousands of
materials and then they can use the
simple tron to rapidly characterize
thousands of materials so the bottleneck
is really about you know inferring the
crystal structures form the x-ray
diffraction data and and you know this
is you see here you have you know a
bunch of samples x-rays these are like
the spectra grams of fact and what you
want to do is to infer from this the
crystal structure so this is a data
interpretation problem why is it so
exciting because you know for us you
know this defies the current state of
the art of machine learning because we
have to produce results that obey
physical laws and so hard constraints
that are difficult to inform enforce and
this is essential you currently a manual
task just for you to see that yes this
problem is very specific but actually
this problem is very it's a source
separation problem you are given a
signal you want to in this
case from the signal identify different
crystal structures we are working on
other problems right
they may look very different for example
monitoring elephants in in Africa where
we have audio signal and there we want
to separate the elephant calls from the
bird calls from the gunshots etcetera so
from a computational point of view these
problems are actually very similar and
you probably are familiar with another
source separation or problem that is
topic modeling that is you know like use
so in a variety of settings so we
develop you know an AI platform using
you know exciting algorithms in machine
learning and matrix factorization and
that led actually it to the discovery of
a new platinum free catalyst and that is
very exciting and actually more recently
we our collaborators again using the
system that we deploy that again the
joint center of fortitude show
photosynthesis Cornell and slack at
Stanford they they discovered a new
family of solar lights absorbers so our
you know big picture for this example is
actually to use AI and other techniques
to to build
asara female robot that is going to
change show me that is a wrap up how I
will so Sarah is actually stands for
scientific autonomous reasoning multi
age ages that is in will encapsulate the
full scientific discovery cycle from
formulating hypotheses
and planning experiments and analyzing
results and combining all kinds of
informations like you know like a very
scientific Q&A system including you know
quantum mechanics etc so you know again
this is a very exciting research area
even though we have these different
applications we have this underlying
prospecting themes from publication work
themes and and you know I for example I
talked about you know the material
discovery that was the last topic but
you know this problem also is similar
when it comes to elephant fall detection
and all you know our electricity usually
disaggregation so there are many
problems that fall into the same
framework so to wrap up this is a very
exciting area in on one hand we think we
can inject computational thinking to
address sustainability questions but
this is really a two-way street you know
we are by studying these sustainability
problems we are exposed to news
challenging problems and also new
formalism and concepts that we get from
other disciplines often very powerful
but they are not powerful from a
computational point of view that's where
we come in and provide our expertise and
obviously the big reward is that we are
doing hope we hope to have societal
impact thank you so much and again I
would like to thank my collaborators
because this is really takes a village
thank you
[Applause]
so how fast does the population of
elephants in Africa decline where do the
whales go
how many turtle hatchlings survive to
adulthood
how many snow leopards are left in the
world
the basic question - the answer to which
we actually do not know are you seeing
red less the International unit on
conservation of nature which is the
official body that determines the
conservation status has this to say
about snow leopard population many of
the most estimates are acknowledged to
be rough and out-of-date the best we
have is about 15 years ago Snow Leopard
the iconic species elephant the effort
was to get a very rough estimate of the
savanna elephants to two million dollars
in two years and it's not scalable or
repeatable scientists cannot track all
animals at all times everywhere we can
put GPS color as a radio colors but
those are actually dangerous take a lot
of effort cost thousands of dollars per
animal to put one on and can be
dangerous to the animals themselves
unfortunately so what do we do today
images are the most abundant readily
available source of information about
animals about wildlife we're really
actually about many many other things as
well so they come from camera traps
field assistants tourists such as Safari
goers of whale watchers park visitors
accidental photographers and Instagram
Flickr and and everything else if it can
only actually get the information
extracted from those images on the
animals right so we do we try so we
built a system that can do just that
that can take thousands of images from
any source and get the information
on who is the animal where it is and
when of the image taken and then from
from all kinds of sources with all kinds
of citizen science input into the system
at every stage from the data collection
to tagging an annotation but also the
education at the end but the system then
can also be queried for all the
information for scientists and
conservation managers so here is it how
it works so can you find all the
elephants or zebras and these images
come on so we can we can pull out use
all the images containing different
species and pinpoint not only that this
is zebra giraffe but also where exactly
the animal is so that's not a big
shocking revelation that it's done using
deep convolutional neural nets we pull
out more than the location of the animal
the localization of the animal in the
image we also the position which is
different for different animals the
viewpoint the quality of the image and
so on and then not only will tell you
that this is a zebra but we can ask
which particular zebra is it of all the
Zebras out there so this is it at a
zebra and Willy the whale and ter the
turtle and we can do it for anything
stripes spotted wrinkled notched or
uniquely identifiable animal I'm
wrinkles are uniquely identifiable
animal or fluke or fins and so together
that's the research paper that gave rise
to oldest and so together with
information on when and where the images
were taken we now actually can track an
animal over over time we can counter
this is an example of the system well
books for several species of cetaceans
humpback whale sperm whales and dolphins
dalton's we called slick book because we
the shape and the color force were
available for the patterns on the flukes
of the whales or the dorsal fins of the
Dolphins for identification
and so this is the celebrity the most
cited in the entire fluid book which now
started out with about 800 individuals
Mountain has more than 11,000 identified
individuals about two years later and
this is the celebrity celebrity whale
pinky she so she's been cited more than
five hundred twenty times this is all
her social network who she's been cited
with and then there is the other
biological sample she also has a calf
when all that and then but she hangs out
all five hundred sightings around this
tiny island in the Caribbean Dominica
just doesn't go far but with this
information we can now really do
population counts and birth death
dynamics and species range and social
interaction and interspecies interaction
as well as the interactions with a
habitat when the information is
available so not only that but so this
is an example of another whale a wild
book this is for whale sharks you can
adopt an animal so people now start
adopting animal you can see who else has
seen this animal and and you can form
collaborations of these researchers and
citizen scientists who've seen who cited
the same animal
we now scrape YouTube images daily for
to identify so we use we pull out the
frames that contain whale sharks and
then use natural language processing to
get the location of the video from the
speech around or from the audio of the
video itself so I looked at whale shark
yesterday and I was showing it to a few
people and from yesterday to today
overnight scraping added three sharks to
the database
so this is this this system started with
about 200 individuals it's a volunteer
effort by divers and people interested
in whale sharks 200 individuals 15 years
ago the initial database didn't have
computer vision until recently and today
it's more than 8,000 so the latest
numbers just to flipped up 8400 41
individuals so this is when I put the
talk together a couple of days ago so
now it's 8 4 84 41 with almost 40,000
sightings more than 5,000 citizen
scientists of participating okay so
that's scale it allows us now not only
to to you know create a database but
this now this wild book for whale sharks
is the basis for the official number of
the global population size estimate by
IUCN Red List okay
the first deployment of wild book was at
the labor Conservancy in the in Kenya
it's the only in Esther world heritage
site in Kenya in January 2015 that's the
duct-tape version when we just kind of
threw everything together and it was
used so this is a server that is
standalone server it Laila Thank You
Microsoft there's a long story of how it
actually got to Kenya there's even a
footage of it somewhere but it's used
there to monitor the Grevy's zebras
which is the endangered species of
zebras and they normally do a monthly
patrol so this is the headquarters also
of the gravy's zebra concentration trust
they do monthly patrols where they take
pictures of the animals they have Palm
Pilot with all the information that the
answer and they have it separate GPS
device and then they come back and use
an excel sheet to upload all that
information and by site identify the
individual animals from the photograph
that's until we deploy the system also
until it applied the system they have a
sense that they're not enough
juveniles surviving to adulthood in the
population even though the numbers
overall scene seemed ok but you know if
the numbers of juveniles sir if the
numbers of juveniles are not if not
fewer than the adults then what's
happening the population is declining
right and so why do we think that
they're not enough juveniles surviving
to adulthood in a Preserve in a native
Conservancy where the nobody is shooting
them Oh lion they're doing also a great
job on lion conservation so there are
too many lions so after the system
deployment and it has been running for
several months they actually had hard
numbers evidence that indeed there not
enough juvenile surviving to adulthood
and we these numbers now they could go
to the Kenya Wildlife Service and start
a population management program for
lions don't get scared this
contraception so last January in 2016 we
did the first ever full census of an
entire species using people driving
around taking pictures so this is the
same very zebra 98% of whom are 95% are
of the species are in Kenya there are a
few hundred and SEO peon and for two
days hundreds of people all over the
country from local tribal chiefs and
kids with we have donations of GPS
enabled cameras to tourists with
telephoto lenses and US ambassador to
Kenya both codecs drove around 280
thousand images 40,000 of them actually
contain zebras we identified each animal
and got the most accurate count of the
species ever in history this is the
number now officially that IUCN Red List
uses so we've done and verified not only
that the saturation the sighting of new
animals over the two days flattened out
essentially we've got every single
animal
out there the compliance rate among all
these hundreds of people with minimum
instruction was very high we could use
about half of the images that they were
that they took which is high they
covered the area that we asked them to
cover going to the northernmost borders
of Kenya to the southern so this is the
very zebra trees but the line separating
so this is the line separating the two
maps which events to the southern wall
streeters they covered the country they
had good coverage and which resulted in
the most accurate count because of that
so this is a graduate student who led
the whole data analysis and supported
the whole system Jason palm from
Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute so as I
said now this is the official number for
there you see n Red List population
count yeah so we we started already
not only from taking data not only from
scientist and field assistant and
tourists and citizen scientist but we
can start going to an online platform
for citizen science and Instagram and
Flickr and Bing and Google and YouTube
as we'll ready solve for whale sharks
but if we are going to take this data
from Flickr how biased our estimates are
going to be that's the question that we
were concerned with and the comma and
the collaboration with Microsoft
Research Lucas and Amber Kidman on
estimating the bias of social media so
we start with a true population there is
a spatial temporal bias of actually
being able to see an animal when you're
there so being at the right time at the
right place but that's the buzz that's
known regardless of photographs right
the next thing is what people given that
they seeing all these animals there's a
bias in what people are going to
photograph we've taken pictures from the
same cart or car going on a safari and
some photographs only birds and take 500
pictures of those and others will take
12 pictures of now a beautiful elephant
one Rhino that's
so as though they should be completely
different towards the next part of bias
is the what they're going given what
they picture that they took what they're
actually going to put on social media
and on which social media right and then
how do we collect that data they would
take only only publicly available images
what kind of search terms are we
entering how do we scrape it and then
how do we estimate which model from that
do we use to estimate the actual
population but what really really
matters is not figuring out exactly all
these biases but they match between the
true population and the true popular and
the population estimate right that's our
error not the combined which represents
the combiner but we don't need to know
exactly H at one of those and so we've
done one of my just graduated students
master student treatise Menon in
collaboration with Microsoft we've done
in Amazon Mechanical Turk study of
asking people given these sets of
pictures that people took on the gravy
zebra rally the great great Israeli the
count of Greater Zebras to select which
once they was boss I mean it's obvious
which one they would choose for to post
on social media from these ones right
it's this one right then so we asked for
each picture would you post it which you
posted so the amazing thing is the
results yes there's a lot of bias and
it's very clear which pictures make it
to the social media or not but the
eventual counts are not biased to
species to age of the animals to the
viewpoint to the identity of individuals
but you know the time of the day is the
night ones are not making it so that was
the amazing result that from all of this
it actually doesn't matter with respect
to the question that we're interested in
we can estimate the actual so this is
the basis we can actually reasonably
accurate estimate the population size
from all resulting from all of these
biases right this will learn about
problems and there seems to be evidence
that there is no actual animal
bias towards any specific animal from
all of this too
so much so that with grape flicker
public images for Grevy's zebras and
decided to compare them to the popular
simplest population estimate from those
to the population estimate that we had
from the great great Israeli from a
massive citizen science effort so we
remember we're comparing it against
January 2016 so the only thing that
matters is really this estimate right so
we're comparing it against January 2016
and here's the error less than 1% error
by taking pictures from Flickr public
images we can get an estimate okay so we
don't know if it only works for graded
zebras is the only works for this
particular year so we're continuing this
study but this and how itself shocked
just all all of us so we now have built
about a dozen of these wild books for
different species so where they showed
you well good for whale sharks well book
for cetaceans flipbook in collaboration
with World Wildlife Fund we have now
several projects this one is for the
Sami ringed seals in Finland they had
estimated 298 left in the world they're
highly endangered we now have 305 in our
wild book so clearly they're more than
they thought one of the project
collaborations so in depth with WWF else
we have project a well book for links
where they're in links and my favorite
internet of turtles IOT the real one all
right so machine learning and beta
science in a smart way
allowed us to take this Veda scarce but
critical data critical discipline you
know of of studying wildlife and
infiltration and allowed us to go from
images from pixels to science
conservation and impalas and public
engagement at a scale and resolution
never seen before over
space and time and individual animals
and clear lives is a joint effort of
many many many people so this is the
wild look as the four co-founders from
so let me pull them out the Andrew
Burstein is an ecologist from Princeton
University
Chuck Stuart is computer vision
scientist from Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute and Photoshop here is Jason
Homburg data architect from wild meat at
org and Lucas wolf it's a different trip
so we'll Photoshop you separately Lucas
has been to Kenya this has been taken in
Kenya and so there's a there is Lucas
and Emory with the large sub with
support from many wonderful
organizations including Microsoft
Research thank you very much
[Applause]
hello
okay Thank You Lucas for organizing this
wonderful session and Thank You Carl I'm
Tanya Farah your Greek box so I'm going
to be talking about in AI for odds on AI
for protecting wildlife forests and fish
so the work I'm going to talk about has
been conducted at the USC Center for AI
in society this is a collaboration
between our School of Engineering in
School of Social Work I'm a co-director
of the center from the AI side and Eric
rice is a co-director from the Social
Work side our mission is to advance AI
research using the Grand Challenges the
thirteen Grand Challenges of the
American Academy of Social Work and
social welfare I've listed just a few
and these are big things like ending
homelessness achieving equal opportunity
and justice and great things and the
international version of this is of
course the UN sustainable development
agenda that Carla brought up now clearly
these are Grand Challenges what can we
practically really do so I'm going to
highlight three areas of work at our
Center the first borrowing from Lucas's
AI for us is indeed focus on AI for our
pal one concrete project that I'll focus
on in my talk today is work we are doing
the Wildlife Conservation Society and
Uganda wildlife Authority in trying to
protect endangered species in Uganda and
the challenge here is these snares that
get placed so if we can using machine
learning predictor snares or place and
get them removed before they kill
animals we can save wildlife and we can
generate patrols to get these snares
removed
I'll show results where we've done this
work and over several months now allowed
snares to be removed potentially saving
lives of animals and poachers to get
arrested in this area also is a work
we're doing at another NGO in drone
patrols in South Africa and detecting
poachers and animals in the infrared
video and then we can send Rangers to
try to introduce the poachers I may not
get time to talk about this and I'm
certainly not going to get time to talk
about some of the other projects that
we've done work
the US Coast Guard degenerate patrols in
the Gulf of Mexico against illegal
fishing and worked with an NGO in
Madagascar that are try to prevent
illegal logging now this work builds
upon our prior work on AI for public
safety and security which is also
another area of work at our center the
challenge here is that we have a large
number of targets to protect but limited
security resources how do you then
schedule or plan or allocate limited
resources we appeal to game theory and
by solving massive scale games we can
generate patrols for example for the US
Coast Guard in different ports like Los
Angeles Boston New York assign air
marshals to flight and work with other
agencies in the Los Angeles area so
briefly touch upon this as this is a
background for some of the work we are
excited that several researchers around
the world are picking this up for
example professor Reed Krause in Israel
is using this to do traffic monitoring
other collaborators in Singapore to
generate patrols in Singapore and for
drug interdiction and so forth a third
area of work that I'll not get to talk
about today morning but please come to
my talk today afternoon if you are
interested is AI for low resource
communities this is work that we are
doing with for example a concrete
project here is a working with the
homeless shelters in LA a challenge is
how do you spread information about HIV
amongst homeless youth harnessing the
social network of these youth we are
able to show that AI algorithms can
spread information far more widely
compared to the traditional methods
we've done pilot tests in homeless
shelters and shown that this is more
effective our algorithms are more
effective in spreading information it's
not only spreading information a
concrete result are these are smiling
youth so sometimes they our programs
provide a bias in a very positive way
and I'll talk more about it later today
the other projects in the space are AI
for intervening in substance abuse and
in suicide prevention these are all
ongoing projects now all of this work is
only possible because of partnerships
with different organizations in the
space of wildlife conservation
it's a partner
ship with WWF WCS and other NGOs in
public safety and security it's with the
US Coast Guard and TSA another law
enforcement agencies in LA and for low
resource communities is with homeless
shelters like safe place for youth in my
French place as I said today morning I'm
only going to be focusing on wildlife
conservation and briefly touch on our
work on public safety and security now
people are very well aware of the
tremendous loss in elephants and rhinos
and so forth to understand the situation
firsthand we I went to Murchison Falls
National Park in Uganda there's
wonderful wildlife there but that
stretch to the wireless there's
thousands of them used to trap animals
so in order to combat that we've been
building this system called paws
protection assistant for wildlife
security the challenge for paws is that
we have massive forest areas thousands
of square miles and limited the security
resources how can we generate
intelligently randomize patrols in these
forests and these need to be based on
learning adversity models so to
understand more of these patrolling
problems we've been to different areas
for example this is a patrol boat in
Bangladesh for the global tiger
conference that we were at this is a
conference the only conference have been
where we got police protection as we
walked out of the countries hasn't
happened that triple a are each guy is a
another trip we went on patrol with
Rangers in Indonesia so one of the side
effects of this work is our ability to
go to all these wonderful places and and
you know understand the challenge that
they face on the top right-hand corner
there is a Frank who's worked PhD worked
this part of this talk is borrow from Al
highlight the role of the lead PhD
student in the stocks in the top
right-hand corner so let's start with
generating intelligently randomized
patrols said this work builds on our
prior work on AI for public safety and
security and for the benefit of those
who may not be aware I'm going to give a
two to three minute introduction to this
work which is
overtake conducted over 10 years and so
this work started in 2007 with lax
police the airport police saying you
know how to allocate checkpoints roads
they're seen 18 bound roads at the
airport not enough a scissors a
terminals not enough dogs
how can you schedule or plan or allocate
these security resources so we've been
using again theoretic approaches now
this is of course rock-paper-scissors
and the outcome is determined by who
wins and who loses and if you are
advising player a you would say you know
randomize over rock paper and scissors
and that's the basic insight that we use
in solving these games when we talk
about games between the police and an
adversary the game is much more
complicated there's a lot more
strategies the payoffs are much more
complicated but it's still a game and
we're solving it to generate random AI
strategies the kind of games we solve
are called cycle burg security games the
security gains in the sense that they
played over target the payoffs are based
on where the targets are covered or not
these are Stackelberg games because the
defender acts first they generate
randomize patrols the adversary can
observe that and then react so the main
challenge of course is to solve these
massive scale games and by solving these
games for example when they were
deployed at the airport sometimes they
lead to arrests of people carrying large
number of weapons into the airport I was
very happy ten years on now two weeks
ago we had a conference at USC and the
police chief was saying we use game
theory so I was very happy to see that
people and so on this has now gone on
with the Federal Air Marshal Service so
if you've been on a US air carrier on an
international flight whether there was
an air marshal or not is a problem that
solve using these games for port patrols
in different ports like New York and LA
and Boston that's also sort of patrols
around the Staten Island Ferry this is
our algorithms that work this is
completely and radically changed how the
Coast Guard used to do these patrols and
the threat they are trying to screen
against is somebody trying to ram a
suicide boat into the ferry so this work
has gone on and we need
by many different security agencies
around the world and as I said with our
colleagues and collaborators now we're
very happy to see it being used in many
other countries just to sort of and this
is litter I mean this hat is more
effective we can show it in different
control experiments this is numbers of
ticketless traveller Scot in LA strains
first using game theory versus previous
methods and showing that the game
theoretic approaches can be more
impactful an uncontrolled experiment
here before go after in terms of before
Armour was deployed at LAX to after the
number of arrests have gone up okay so
this is all a previous work how do we
apply it for protecting wildlife so
we're going to take the park area and
divide it up into grid cells one
kilometer by one kilometer each grid
cell is a target now we can play a
security game where if there's a water
body now we know that that has a
high-value target which there's more
animals there now we're going to solve
this game generate randomized patrols
when the adversaries are back poachers
attack targets we get data and from that
crime data we learn an adversary model
and that improves our patrols let's
focus on the game theory portion of this
this can be solved as a security game we
did it
we generated patrols we handed them over
to our collaborators in Uganda Andrew
Lemieux tried them out Panthera tried it
out in Malaysia and the taman negara
forest area there's a poacher scam that
was found but the feedback that kept
giving us is that we aren't paying
attention to geography so we were in LA
there in malaysia and we're having these
Skype calls and they're telling us
backed up you know the shortest distance
between two points is not a straight
line and this didn't make sense so we
flew down to Malaysia ourselves so this
is us a beginning of patrol in the
forest in Malaysia this Bo an a former
postdoc is Fay she's here and me and we
started we're very happy we get to
patrol in Malaysia in the forest hacking
through the forest
finding a poachers camp exhausted at the
end and the guide is telling us you
still have to walk a kilometer but we
understood something important the
shortest distance between two points is
not a straight line in the forest you
have to walk along ridge line ship
walk along riverbeds and these
constraints so there's a hidden street
map that needs to be taken into account
this is what's done in paws that leads
to better patrols and we can now show
that this was a preliminary evaluation
that we can see more human signs
it was patrols compared to previous
patrols but this is generating patrols
now let's look at the other side of the
equation learning adversary model so we
can generate more impactful patrols and
so this is part of a PhD work of my
former student Thai Nguyen and so her
task was to figure out given the set of
grid squares where would an adversary
attack and so we have past crime data
from the Queen Elizabeth National Park
12 years of data and we're trying to
predict based on the different features
that have we have been given how likely
is an attack gonna take place on a grid
square so we have Ranger patrol
frequency animal density distance to
roads and rivers area slope etc etc so
the first attempt was to build a dynamic
Bayes net it's a two layered model
attack probability and detection
probability because when a ranger goes
to a location they may not actually find
an attack and so we want to predict
these probabilities using all these
features we did this unfortunately it
seemed like there's just not enough data
over the entire park and so we needed
somehow to figure out how to you know
how to get around this problem so we ran
a hackathon within our group to figure
out who might come up with a better
model and the model that seemed to win
was an ensemble of decision trees which
feature boosting and this basically you
do a majority vote and said this is the
area where this is the one kilometer by
one kilometer grid Square where an
attack is going to take place this
prediction can be improved in localized
places where there is more patrolling
going back to this earlier dynamic Bayes
net model which is more data hungry and
so using all of this we ran simulations
so this is looking at given path data
from previous years can we predict
attacks in 2015 and so on the y-axis is
LnL score a metric of accuracy you can
see that the best model we have
significantly more better performing
than other models that we had other
standard machine learning models we
could throw at this problem but this is
data from 2015 what would happen in 2016
so here we first did a one month pilot
test we chose to nine square kilometer
areas these were deliberately chosen to
be areas where there were infrequent
patrols there were no previous attacks
and you're trying to see we're sort of
saying you haven't patrolled these areas
we predict you will find attacks in
these areas and to make it more
interesting you know this was done one
month before the ammos deadline if you
find the tax there's a paper if there's
no tax there's no paper and so this is
the way we found these found these
places and look at this these green
spots you can see they don't overlap
with the red the red are the previously
cited seam attacks and this is you know
other again the Reds are far away from
the green so we are asking them to
patrol it completely new areas and say
here's where you're going to find snares
okay and so the Rangers get the data and
this is how they're patrolling proceeds
they'll walk out and in this case you're
lucky they found a snare and now they'll
record it and we get to know there's a
snares useless orlando's so we started
you know to nine square kilometre areas
first emails started coming in from
Uganda okay there's a nineteen signs of
liquor and so forth well doesn't quite
help us it's good to know one active
snare that's good and then approach to
elephant so that's sad but it tells us
that we are in the right spot we are in
the right place we the poachers are
active in this area but in this case we
are too late but then one whole elephant
snare rolls so for church were active in
this area they were killing elephants
but before they could kill the next
batch of elephants a snare roll that was
hidden away was removed and obviously
hopefully this means that we save some
animals and then 10 more antelope snares
and so on should point out that I'd also
given the students a reward every snare
found would be a drink a free drink on
me
at the at the end of up to this they
were okay then they said okay no more
drinking here so this is this is a
historic or hit rate compared to the
historical hit rate is higher hit rate
desire and so this is a good pilot test
enormous paper got done but let's raise
the stakes and say you know run a larger
scale there six months and this is for a
thesis so if you succeed your thesis
gets completed and so here there's 27
areas the nine square kilometers each we
divided them up some we said were high
areas where you will find more snares
some low areas where you will not find
many snares five areas were high 22
areas were low according to the
proportion of high and low in this park
and there's a lot of constraints on
where the ideas could be there to be
certain distance away from patrol posts
all of that and the Rangers were trained
to use the software to go out and find
find these locations they were unaware
of this classification they were not
told which were high and which were low
and they went out and we measure effort
in terms of catch per unit effort for
every kilometer walk how many snares
were found the Rangers walked hundreds
and hundreds of kilometers trying to
look for snares and the question is what
would really happen and so fortunately
our high where we predicted the capture
would be high the catch per unit effort
was 0.11 where we said there will be
fewer snares catch per unit effort to
0.01 a tenfold difference and so clearly
we are making we are doing good job
predicting where snares would be located
and in fact the historical catch per
unit effort is 0.04 so wait so the
ranges when they are walking by
themselves without the use of our
software their hit rate is much lower
and so based on this we are very happy
that thisis got completed etc but
there's very interesting side effects so
as the ranges were following the put you
know going out to do this experiment one
day they said well we found the poachers
trail they followed the trail found the
camp ambushed the camp arrested poachers
confiscated wire snares and cooking pots
and
all sorts of things we can't report this
as part of the experiments outside our
area but the good side effect other
areas they chase poachers I wish we had
a video of that in one of the areas
other kinds of things that were found so
the goal here now given that this seems
to be working is to really test it more
expensively in other parks Murchison
Falls National Park with the WCS in
Cambodia and with WWF and hopefully
include this in the smart software so
that it can be deployed worldwide in
predicting poaching I wanted to close
here in the last few minutes by talking
about another project is patrolling from
the sky this has worked with the air
Shepherd and NGO
I worked on my PhD student Liz Bondi and
so the drone flies idea is that if we
can in real time figure out where the
poachers are where the animals are then
we can call in the Rangers and try to
interdict interdict poaching so this is
a nighttime we get these real-time video
and this is three poachers hiding that
were found and so forth so I'll end here
by saying that you know there's a whole
lot more that can be discussed but
running out of nine so let me talk about
the main points there's significant
potential for AI to contribute in this
effort and you know congratulate Lucas
for starting this effort on AI for work
but these are not just applications of
existing technology there are
fundamental computational challenges AI
challenges from this user inspired
research but as we design these
algorithms as we design this new kind of
AI that clearly challenges of understand
ability transparency interpretability
and in complimenting human autonomy
briefly by interpretability I mean when
we say okay you have to go there and
when we first were telling the Rangers
to go to a certain location you are
going to find snares there the question
is why and if it's a very complicated
model and we can't quite explain they're
not going to go it's a lot of effort you
know they're going to work hundreds of
kilometres doesn't work like that
complementing human autonomy got to find
the right balance we can't we know there
is
say one kilometer by one kilometer grid
square whereas where snares may be found
but we won't be able to tell the Rangers
okay they're going to be hidden under
this particular bush that's the kind of
expertise that they have and so figuring
out the right balance has to be
important I'll end by saying that
there's also methodological challenge
here in that this is kind of work which
gets done not in the lab but in the
field and here we are collecting data
from the field and this is not work
we're proving necessarily proving
theorems and algorithms beyond that it's
the next stage where collecting data and
there needs to be a way for us to
encourage this kind of work to be able
to publish this kind of work and this is
very you know a new place for doing this
kind of interdisciplinary work today
unfortunately this may or may this is
likely not going to get accepted at our
conferences so this is something we need
to pay attention to in order to foster
this new kind of science so I'll end
here by saying that there's a tremendous
opportunity for AI for social good and
if you are more into if you are
interested please come to our website
case dot u.s. c dot edu thank you well
thank you guys so much that was I know
all of this work and every time I hear
it I get more ideas for what we need to
do next
Carlos getting some water but we're
going to have all three presenters come
up here we have 15 minutes I believe is
that correct yep we have 15 minutes
first of all I just want to thank the
presenters for actually doing the almost
always unachievable which is sticking to
our time so I will be up here as well
you can ask me questions but you should
ask the presenters questions primarily
and we'll kind of go in a first-come
first-served sort of sort of way with
questions so that was impressed
so yeah let's go and I believe there
will be a microphone walking around from
from person to person so Kishu around
with champion from Georgia Tech all
three talks are fascinating being
assistance guy this is completely new
for me so I was really blown away about
by the talks but I have question for all
three of you starting with the very
first talk you know it covered a lot of
different domains and and and you gave
Steiner tree as one example of a
computational model just curious whether
there are different you know easily go
domains do they require different kind
of arsenal of computational models to be
brought to bear so experience from that
would be something that I would like to
know and for the second panelist you you
mentioned the difference between false
positives you know the error rates I'm
just curious how you go about detecting
the error rates in that so you know that
that would be interesting and and then
the answer the third panelist this is
fascinating work and I was a little bit
disturbed to hear that this may not be
accepted in consciousness I wanted you
to elaborate on that thank you
and you know what I find facts
fascinating and actually I try to
emphasize is you know what we observe is
there's a variety of problems that
actually you know occur in in in
different settings across different
applications and you can actually get
these synergies for example you know
connectivity is studying connectivity
you know we have studied connectivity in
and you know graph theory is finer tree
and many other many other problems in
network design well it just happens you
know there are many
problems in computation sustainability
that can be captured as graphs and for
example we that we encounter those
problems to study to design wildlife
carcass or if it's actually interesting
I'm a big believer in serendipity in
fact a colleague who was familiar with
our work
concerning all wise conservation and
connectivity you know by understanding
how we were doing it understood what
optimization is and how computer science
can provide you know tremendous insights
and he immediately thought oh this is
really very similar to you know placing
or studying the placement of hydropower
dams in in the Amazon indeed again there
we have these questions how you know the
placement of the dams are affecting
connectivity so you know you do see
these themes and this cross
computational topic or even problem
recur you know in different domains not
just sustainability and in fact you know
I think that it makes it very exciting
for computer science I also gave the
example of work we are doing in terms of
source separation for material discovery
where you have a signal you know x-ray
diffraction patterns and you want to
identify different factors or crystal
structures in these images and you know
that problem is you know similar to
separating you know elephant calls from
other sounds so you know you have and we
are identifying these cross-cutting
computational things and that makes it
very exciting for the students in fact
typically you know my students work I
have these a variety of domains that we
they can apply methodologies you know
some algorithm developments for material
discovery elephants calls etc so I hope
I addressed your yoga yoke wretched so
just to add and maybe answer this I
think every kind of computational
abstraction has a match in some
biological or sustainability domain
question what is what I found both
exciting and challenging in working in
this domain is in I'm a computational
ecologist and have been for many years
now working with ecologists is first of
all it takes about a year quite often to
figure out what how to translate the
domain question into the right
computational abstraction at least yeah
because the second aspect of it is that
we quite often will we're used to having
okay we have our solution let's now test
it against ground truth we will not have
ground truth in most of these problems
in most of these in this domain so we
have to find different ways of verifying
our answer and the third aspect of it is
that our computational objectives quite
often are mismatched for the utility of
the solution in the domain and so it
takes a while
not only to translate the question into
the right abstraction but find the right
translation back from the computational
answer to the utility function in the
domain so but in terms of which kinds of
abstractions everything I would like to
take the this whole specific negative
question offline because it's pretty
technical so there is a problem we have
in our conferences I'll be run this
experiment inadvertently in our lab
where within one office we had one for
start doing the same problem proving
theorems and other postdoc going out and
measuring things in the field guess
which paper got a best paper nomination
which paper got rejected and the standby
review was essentially you measure
things in the field but you didn't
develop new algorithms there's no
theorems and the papers out and so
unfortunately a kind of work which is
really this is measuring things in the
field is not easy this requires a lot of
effort this kind of work is not
appreciated and there needs to be a
space within our conferences where this
kind of work is recognized today we
smuggle it in in application tracks in
data science tracks but this is science
and this should be recognized as a
primary citizen of of our conferences
and it needs to be a place to do that
and if that doesn't happen students
postdocs are not they're not going to do
this kind of work we had a visitor from
wildlife conservation society all of
last week and he kept saying you got to
do more measurements you have to do this
you have to do field tests you have to
test it on other datasets and the PhD
students are very concerned that this is
not going to lead to any publications
this is but but it's really important
and why this emphasis to just keep
coming up with newer models and show
that it shows a little bit of
improvement over the last model is
that's how you get papers published and
this is wrong and there needs to be a
fix and I think we need to come up with
a new space to encourage this kind of
work so one of the reasons we have
mellon here actually what I'm just going
to follow up on that before and we'll go
over there next I would just I strongly
concur I would just say that there is
several hundred of the top AI
researchers at faculty summit today and
so when we complain about the way that
things are done we are them right so you
know there's a reason that I asked these
three to be here today because they
they're not the only ones but they're in
my mind they're exemplars of people who
have gone out and work to change the
system but they're their careers and
credibility on the line to say these are
things that are important I come from
the other side on the environmental
science
side I've started an emerging
technologies track at one of the largest
ecology journals to directly start
publishing computer science applications
in the environmental sciences domain
Tonya's on editorial board say whom
Ellen mentioned is on the editorial
board so I'd just like to say that you
know there's a problem but if anyone's
going to fix it it's us and also if we
take a slightly less myopic view of
things from triple-a I or H comp or nips
and you asked how do you publish in the
world's biggest journals in science and
nature that is a struck you need strong
algorithmic advances and you need
significant contributions to the science
itself so as computer science and and
artificial intelligence domains start
looking at the at the bigger scientific
enterprise and getting the message out
in in that domain I think if you look at
the recent issue of science was it last
week or two weeks ago that was dedicated
towards AI the the feature article was
the new scientific assistant right where
they're looking for AI to be applied
strongly to scientific domains like
environmental science in ecology so
alright so I'm before hitting my
question I just have to respond to this
particular topic because it seems to me
as somebody who loved applications why
would you want to waste publishing an
application in a conference about the
theory of machine learning I mean take
it to an environmental science
conference that's going to be the place
where it's really exciting and has
impact but the question I had for you
you seem to you've taken something which
there terrifies the civil libertarians
as a primer for all of you but I think
primarily for Tanja this idea of a
global surveillance society and shown
the wonderful things that you can do
with it and I wonder if you have thought
about turning some of that back towards
asking the same questions about human
populations so finding missing people
doing real-time demographics of sort of
ethnicities in different areas studying
the migrations of people from place to
place there seems to be some wonderful
opportunities there if you can
those little civil liberties issues
right right so thank you David we
actually get invariably asked that
question so when is the world booked for
humans coming it's called Facebook
actually but I agree I mean and and this
surveillance for humans is orders of
magnitude ahead of what we can do for
animals facial recognition for humans is
much better than than what we can do for
animal ID so I would actually switch the
answer we can do already a lot of we're
doing what we're doing for animals we
already can do it for humans I'm not
touching it hi Barbara gross Harvard um
first I just want to say I to applaud
what you're doing
and I'm extremely sympathetic as millon
knows to the issue of publishing so just
a few thoughts one is of course as you
know anything that involves human
subjects also has this problem I will
say one of the advantages that people
who collect big data like the NLP world
now is by sharing the data they have
they've made actually the collection of
data important I think first of all I
think Lucas your comment about
publishing in other journals is exactly
right it's a lot of work to get that
data and so there's a tendency to say
you know do I really want to share it so
other people can just do the algorithmic
part and I think with the NLP world at
least has shown is that there is an
advantage and then it becomes a good
thing to have collected it so you might
think about that the bottom line though
is I think I think that you're right
so but I would urge towards thinking
about open data so I guess I was a
comment more than a question though you
all can't respond to that and I know how
hard it is to make data available to
others that also there are huge privacy
concerns for for example both for
villains and my work for share
during the data and privacy and security
of animals all so for there there are
several wild books that we will never
put online for cheetahs in South Africa
for example they the seals one is closed
if we ever get the snow leopard one
going it's not going to be accessible
because those are highly the data is
highly valuable to poachers so sharing
data has to be done very very carefully
you know actually in some cases more
carefully than for humans and I'm sure
for melon so sharing data is great but
we haven't figured out the right model
for this domain I think yeah but we can
take we can so I'm I'm I've talked about
it with Ross Anderson from Cambridge
University who has done the privacy
model for healthcare and he says this is
more complicated okay thank you very
much I know the Q&A session went by
extremely quickly but everybody's
already milling around outside because
everyone else did their jobs better and
ended their sessions on time I would
just like to thank the three panelists
and speakers today thank you so much
everything you guys do is what inspires
me to do a little bit more in that world
everyday and thank you guys all for
coming
and hearing about this and please do
reach out to me about the AI for Earth
program if you're interested thank you
so much
you
[Applause]